[Music]
i caught her seeing another guy i put
her as the center of my world
my happiness relied on her she wasn't
happy i wasn't happy and i know i put a
lot of stress on her because of that i
could have been better okay
um you could have been better and she
could have made different choices too
[Music]
dude last night me and my friends had a
90s sing-along
here in nashville
we got some free tickets to go see third
eye blind and taking back sunday like
it's
1998. like two things one go to shows
with your friends so fun man even even
if they're not your jam just go anyway
it's a blast
and number two
we've got to as a society as a culture
we've got to make like a take a stand
and this has to be a bipartisan
everybody comes together on this
we all have to agree there needs to be
an age limit for who can purchase
clothes for themselves at hot topic
i think just globally speaking
um if you're over
19 you can't go into hot topic and think
this looks cool i'm gonna buy this for
me now i've done that i've actually i've
bought hot topic things in the mall as a
grown up so i'm speaking to myself here
but as i looked around and on stage i
thought
you're too old for that you're too old
and it's a good reminder to me that as i
age
i should have less um
baby pins on my clothes and less zippers
in the middle of my back and things like
that that
don't have much of a utilitarian
function but sure
look cool to the 16 year old so i think
as a country if someone would propose
that legislation i'll vote for you i
don't care what much of your other
positions are but if you will make the
great hot topic bill of 2022 i would be
full support hey and this is the dr john
delaney show i'm so glad you're here um
i've got sing-along in my head the it's
the the greatest mental health podcast
ever
said not very many people and i'm glad
you're with us if you want to be on the
show go to johndaloney.com
ask ask
and fill out the form or you can call
one eight four four six nine three three
two nine one it's one eight four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one all
right let's go to bridgette in baltimore
uh what's up bridgette
hi how are you
i'm good how are you
pretty good good what's up
so i have an interesting question
so my stepson who's 20 moved back to the
baltimore area not too long ago
and we were getting our nails done one
day with my husband and him and
he
casually said oh by the way
i had a threesome with my
brother and his wife
and so my husband and i
don't know how to handle that
really
okay so i i the whole picture here is
fantastic
um and by fantastic i mean like highly
disturbing so you and how old are you
i'm 26.
this is even more fantastic how old's
your husband
he's 43. okay
and
all right so
he has remarried somebody basically the
same age as his kids
yes and y'all all three three of you
were out getting manicures together
yes incredible and then i say incredible
i guess that's not that's not a bad
thing to eat your own my dad's never
taken me for a manicure i may hit him up
for one over the holidays
um so the three of y'all are out and
while y'all are getting your manicure
um your
stepson who's the same age as you
says it sounds like a country song um
your stepson is the same age as you
tells you and your husband
hey bt dubs i
had a threesome with my brother and his
wife
yes
was it just like a casual like hey by
the way um starbucks
the the pumpkin spice lattes are coming
out early this year oh and uh i mean it
was it like that was it like a big
pretty much
he didn't i mean he didn't really think
anything of it he thinks it's totally
fine
all right so there's no way
i know i've met with some folks who have
some um very outside the bell curve
sexual preferences proclivities
eve nobody would think this is super
normal or super cool what was the
follow-up conversation like
there was nothing so that's what i found
upsetting is my husband didn't really
say anything about it
because he he has pcsd from being in the
army and he says nothing really shocks
him so he didn't really find it that
all right so
not responding to that has nothing to do
with ptsd
okay
it doesn't it's not like uh
nothing can shock you fine ptsd is a
diagnostic that's a whole other that's a
trauma response i i don't that
that was just simply he either froze or
he doesn't care
but yeah that's not those are those i
would not conflate those two things so
let's say that like
how long have you all been married
uh five and a half years okay
um
so you how you were 21
yes
and you met this strapping 39 year old
how'd that how'd y'all meet
uh facebook
yeah i love the internets of course you
did that's fantastic
wow okay so
what's your question how about that
let's start there
so my question is is
i told my mom this like because i was so
shocked and i didn't get a reaction to
him and i was kind of like how do i
process this so i called my mom why
why'd you call your mom
you're a
you're like a grown married like why'd
you call your mom is she just like a
confidant for you
yeah
oh
okay
okay and so she said that
so
the plot twist of this is that he came
back to the area because there's a plot
twist
i thought this was most of the movie
let's plot twist go go for it
um it's that he is working for my
husband and i so that's why he came back
to the area okay so
i was telling my mom about the situation
and she's like
well you should keep it just
professional because we were taking him
out to eat and trying to help him out i
was going above and beyond doing all
kinds of other stuff for him to help him
out and so my mom's like you should stop
doing that pretty much and take a step
back and just do business with him now
but my husband's like why should you
treat him any differently
because this was in the past and the
reason why he stopped doing this with
his brother and his wife was because he
said he wasn't attracted to his wife so
he would have kept doing it had he found
her attractive
but that means y'all had more than one
conversation about this
or was that after that like this is like
a few weeks ago so i brought it up to
him because i was like i'm a little
disturbed that you're not saying
anything about this and i think you need
to tell him that it's not right
okay and what was the response there
he's like i told him but what you want
me to do cut him off just because
he did something like this and i was
like i don't know
okay
um you're the only person on the phone
with me
and so i am can only talk to you is that
cool
all right
so
um i am a
i don't say outside the box nothing like
your husband nothing surprised me
nothing shocks me anymore okay
um
and i am
almost universally very sympathetic to
situations people find themselves in
whether it's addiction whether it's
sexual chat like whatever wherever they
find themselves
um i always want to
sit down and offer some
offer drink and some nachos let's figure
this out okay
um but nobody else is on the phone but
you and me so i will say
i will boldly state i'm going to go way
out on a line like on a on a thin line
here
and say
having sex with your brother
and your brother's spouse
is pretty screwed up
by any metric
it's um
it's
pretty distorted disturbing behavior
okay but that goes way over here because
that's not the real issue here's the
real issue
you are an adult
five years into a marriage
and you are responding to those around
you like a child
you call your mommy for advice you're
talking to your husband as though he's
your dad
and you are balancing your values and
your safety and your
business
off of
um
you're not making decisions from a
value-based core
okay so the issue here is
yes that is outside the bell curve
that's way out there okay
um anybody listening to this very very
few people will experience their son
having sex with his brother and his wife
right very people
all of us will experience i don't want
to be around x y and z i don't want to
be around certain behaviors i don't want
to work with certain behaviors i'm not
going to have employees that work for me
that act certain ways
and you have to decide what your values
are which you will and will not tolerate
and then you've got to make those
decisions based on your values
that make sense
yes and so let me ask you
do you want to do business with this
person because a you're disgusted by it
but b
i can hear your voice you don't trust
this person
their wisdom their decision-making like
i can hear it in you
um
do you want to do business with this
person
[Music]
i mean if it's just business then he's
okay but personal life there's just a
bunch of crazy stuff that happens with
him that i don't want involved in and
that was my next step is this is one
isolated this is not one i said incident
let me say like that there's gonna be
other behavioral issues is that fair
way
more
okay
so
um
have you sat down and told your husband
i do not want to have meals with this
person i don't want this person in my
home
uh yes and he gets kind of like
defensive okay so there is a challenge
that you found yourself where you're
gonna end up pitting
you and your values versus your husband
and his kids
this is different when they're in home
at home right and this is a i'll tell
folks the opposite of them to tell you
when there are young children at home
you can as a as a
stepmom if you will you can never pit
your
spouse against their kids
this in my mind is different because
this is y'all's home
right these are grown kids lived
somewhere else and now they're circling
back and this is i think you've got
every right to say this is what i
um
need in this home or let me ask you
another question if he lets this kid
move in he's okay he's falling on hard
times he's moving in are you gonna stay
uh we've already done that once
okay
and i mean so the question i mean he has
an apartment so that's not gonna happen
but
oh sweet bridget it could happen any
time
it can happen any time any time
let me so let's just call it like
what are your boundaries going to be
is there ever a moment when you're going
to leave
i don't know
you do know because i have so many
people in my head telling me like oh
it's not wrong it is wrong i know it's
wrong but i don't know how to handle it
like where do i draw the line i know
what nobody thinks that's okay
nobody
nobody
you've had you've had friends and family
tell you dude it's just it's all good
it's cool
not exactly cool but
like everyone's like oh well
i did a facebook poll on it just out of
curry
like it's not your business so stay out
of it because they're
adults hey you know what that's
different that's actually accurate it's
their business
but when it becomes your business is
when that sort of character that sort of
behavior that sort of lack of judgment
and wisdom comes into your home comes
into your business
so you can't make adults stop doing
behaviors
you can't the only person you can
control is you so a never put family
business in a facebook poll good god
bridgette don't ever do that ever
two
that the advice you guys actually
correct
the question you have to ask yourself is
what are you gonna do not what are they
gonna do your husband can't stop them
your
his two sons from having sex together
he yeah he can't
and having threesomes but you can't stop
that what he can stop is
i'm not going to participate in that
world
and let's make it does that mean does
that mean he should just do business or
does that mean we should just cut i
don't do business with people that i
wouldn't share a meal with
okay i don't because business ult you
you can't bifurcate the business there's
a fantastic study and i remember driving
home with my eyes bugging out of my head
that this was a study and that i was
like
didn't we all know this but clearly we
didn't do you remember back in the day
uh you may be a bit young there was um
i think it was it holly madison kelly
the website yeah it was a whole ashley
madison okay it was uh bridget it was a
site called ashley madison and it was a
do you remember that
no okay so it was a
quote-unquote anonymous site for married
people to have affairs with other
married people who are interested in it
and it was kind of like
tinder or
whatever it was like way upstream of
those um it was earlier on but it was
you could put in your email address and
put in your um credit card number and
then meet up with other married people
in your area
somebody leaked all of the email
addresses and there was a big technique
i like famous people and fancy pants
religious like people got busted okay
but a couple of social scientists did a
study they took the addresses
and went and thumbed through
companies and businesses in the u.s and
i'm gonna butcher the details a little
bit but the the findings are i i
remember them
they went through the companies
and found that people who were on this
site who were willing to cheat on their
spouse
had more ethics violations had more
business issues had more
uh had less profits etc why this was
huge was
it had always been known you just need
to get the best baseball player drug
addict cheats on his wife all the time
it's fine because he shows up and
performs on that field
and or get this best ceo does it matter
their ethics they can have a drug
problems crazy stuff have private jets
that fly to islands whatever because
they're gonna show up and they're gonna
produce they're gonna do great and what
this study showed was that if somebody's
willing to cheat on their spouse
they're gonna cheat in their business
if somebody's gonna cut corners in their
personal life they're gonna cut corners
in their business because that's who
they are that's the way they operate in
the world
and so
i tell you that to tell you if there's
decision making happening in somebody's
personal life that's like what are you
doing
i wouldn't trust you with my child then
i'm not going to trust you with my
business
the other side of that is this
at the company i work for um
they give us all debit cards
debit cards not credit cards they give
us debit cards
and one of my favorite things about my
boss um
his business buddies are like i can't
believe you would trust your employees
with debit cards to the company account
and his response is i can't believe you
would hire people to run your business
that have your family's name attached to
it
that you don't trust enough with your
money if you're going to trust them with
your name you see what i'm seeing i'm
going here there is no difference
between business and and personal when
it comes to
i trust you here but not here
i just feel bad because he quit his job
to come out here and work for us so
that's why i feel guilty too
and so
now this becomes about you trying to
um squash how you feel
squash your values squash what's
important to you
because somebody else is going to feel
bad
the the non-technical term is you're a
people pleaser you're a peacemaker
and peacemakers often go to other people
to ask for how they should feel about
things
yeah like their parents even though
they've been married for five years like
their
spouse even though they're disgusted and
they feel not right and not level okay
see what i'm saying
yeah
and i want to make real clear
give me a couple of examples of other
behaviors that make you just say no no
no no no no i don't want this person in
my house
so
he used to call the cops
um on my husband and
make up that he was beating him to try
to get his dad in trouble because he
wouldn't let him go like out with his
friends and stuff like that okay
so you've got integrity issues and
you've got wisdom issues right
yeah yeah is there um
substance abuse issues as well
uh no
i would challenge
that stone's tone stone sober
as far as i know
i i
i said earlier i'm i don't get shocked
by much i would be shocked by that
here's the deal so you've got this
outside of the bell curve situation
right
um
yeah you've got somebody in your life
that's doing life differently than your
set of values the first thing you got to
do is you got to sit down and identify
what your values are
what's the life you want to live what's
the life you want to lead
um
you cannot change other people's
behavior
so your internet poll was right
like the people are going to do what
they're going to do right and i'm all
about letting people do what they want
to do
um
the only person i can control is me
and the only person you can control
bridget is you
so i
at some point you gotta say here's what
i'm gonna tolerate my life and here's
what i'm not here's what i'm gonna share
meals with and here's what i'm not
um
and the people that i've had at my at my
house stay at my home
um
across the spectrum would would shock
people i love having people in my house
i like my kids meeting a wild array of
wonderful different people
my life is enriched by that
um
but one common thread through all the
people that stay at my home all the
people i consider friends all people i
consider people that i love
has very little to do with political
spectrum has very little to do with
whether i agree with all their behaviors
or not
has way more to do with do i trust them
are they wise are they loving people who
care about me and my family and others
and um
that's not the situation you find
yourself in it sounds like you find
yourself in a situation where you feel
scared and exposed and your eyes just
bug out of your head and you're looking
around saying is everyone else seeing
this
and
everyone's kind of just putting their
head down and saying let's just keep
going let's just keep going and at some
point you gotta look in the mirror and
say i'm cool with this i'm good this is
gonna be what this is gonna be i married
this guy i'm in and so if he's cool i'm
cool
or you're gonna look in the mirror and
say i'm gonna draw a line and say no
and i'd rather choose guilt over
resentment i'd rather feel guilty that i
tell this young man hey either you gotta
make some major life changes so we can
trust you
and your wisdom
and your character or
um you're gonna have to go
you're gonna have to go and you're gonna
feel guilty about it you can feel bad
about it but doesn't mean it's the wrong
thing either that or you're gonna just
live with this behavior over and over
and over and over and over again and by
the way the behavior i'm talking about
is not about him having sex with his
brother and his brother's wife
that's disturbing in its own little
world i'm saying behavior things that
violate your moral compass and violate
your values you're gonna have to at some
point say
this is the line i draw
and uh you might not be able to get rid
of them but you might say i'm gonna
choose to walk thank you very much it's
a twist you gotta make um
and i wouldn't lose a lot of sleep and i
would stop calling my mom and i would
get one or two close friends of mine
who around my age maybe a little bit
older with some wisdom and sit down and
say okay i got some hard decisions to
make here's what comes next
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change save yourself the
headache and call churchill mortgage
today at triple eight loan 200. trust me
that's triple eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go out to
alex in dallas texas what's up alex
hey dr john how are you doing today i'm
good my brother how are you
oh i'm beyond blessed i am beyond
blessed how's the uh fine fine state of
uh texas there i hear it's like the
surface of the sun these days
it's hot it's dry and i lose cell phone
signal about every hour so we're still
working on those 5g towers y'all should
y'all should secede you also just call
it
get rid of the federal government do it
do it on your own
oh man
no comment on that
remember the alamo all right so what's
up man
so i wrote all this down so that way i
can stay on my script and not ramble so
i'll give you a short background and
then my main question so cool
my ex-wife and i divorced back in
december after being together for 10
years five of those years being married
we have no children
here's my main question
how can i best continue to move forward
with my life owning and being proud of
my marriage and my divorce which i do
not regret one second of
but also not let it define who i am as a
person in my professional social and
spiritual life
number one
um
you're still grieving the loss of this
marriage huh
yes i am yeah
how or why did it end
um
there were
she had you know her uh faults i had my
faults i'm not going to lie and say that
i was the perfect husband by any means
she fell out of love with me
she i caught her seeing another guy okay
the issues that i have to realize for
myself was i put her as the center of my
world
my happiness relied on her
she wasn't happy i wasn't happy and i
know i put i know i put a lot of stress
on her because of that okay and um you
know it's very similar to your book um i
have to own that yeah and
um i have to move forward with that
understanding that
i could have been better okay
um you could have been better and um
she could have made different choices
too
yes yeah okay
um so the technical word is love
addiction
where we put another person at the
center of our world right as this anchor
that they're gonna complete us all right
the old tom cruise thing i wrote about
that a little bit in that book
um
and the the
the super technical is codependent right
you've heard that phrase i'm sure
um
here's a couple of
things just to think through
one is
most of us have a picture of our in our
heads
even though it's common
of a divorced person
and then
we look in the mirror
and those two pictures don't align
right
it's hard to see yourself as somebody
who's been divorced
and in our culture we turn everything
into an identity so the words are you're
a divorcee right or is that the right
way to say it like
uh you're divorced as though that's
that's your new label that's your
identity um
instead of somebody who was married to
somebody wasn't perfect and that person
cheated on me
violated our marriage covenant
and um
now i'm
i had gone all in on somebody
and for a love addict for someone who's
codependent you went all in all in all
in you not only put all the cards the
dealer gave you you had some other cards
underneath in your back pocket that you
played too right you played every card
every every i had to steal cards if
that's what it does that's right you put
every card on the table and including
other people's cards that's a great way
to put it
and you still lost the hand
and there's a deflating
right where it's just
ugh
and i think you at some point you
i had this thought the other day um
somebody was on an airplane
and
they had a little kid
a really small kid like a three two or
three year old the cutest little girl
and she's been silly and goofy and also
a little bit grumpy the flight was long
and this person started swearing
started cursing
to the level that
i i was i was
i haven't felt like this in probably a
decade to where i've got just mechanisms
that are i'm gonna end up in a fist
fight
and i could feel my body heading in a
direction that i was like oh man this is
old john i don't know this guy
uh
and i had a thought in that airplane
um that the newspaper would read you
know
40 year old male
and i thought i don't see myself as that
as that black and white label but that's
what i you know that's the reason that's
the truth that's really got to own it
like you said
and then the next statement is so then
what so then what am i going to do so i
chose obviously not to get a fistfight
on an airplane but you've got to just
say okay this is the way this is and
then my question is going to be what am
i gonna do next right
um can i ask you a hard question
yeah of course you haven't let her go
yet have you
i think i'm still holding on to what we
used to have yes
but
i understand
and my heart doesn't want what we had
if that makes sense like i'm i'm holding
on to what we had early
but we
we just drifted over the last several
years our goals changed things we wanted
changed
we still cared about each other i still
i still care about her but
not anywhere what i used to have you
ever have you ever met with a someone
who's really struggles with heroin or
cocaine
or even meth
do you have any friends okay
um
one of the terms they use is chasing the
ghost
the the
the first time you use um folks who
become long-term addicts almost
universally i've heard say
oh i knew i knew that first time whoa
this is going to be a part of my life
and you try to get high again and again
and again chasing that first or second
experience and you can never catch it so
they call it chasing ghosts right and
you're all and you end up doing things
that you know are killing you
in service of chasing that thing
and if you are a true love addict
you can tell me intellectually i know
that wasn't good for me
i've never met somebody who struggles
with meth who's like no this is helping
me out i've never heard that
um
i've never heard met somebody i've
spent time with someone who's doing
heroin who says no this is actually
pretty good for me
so you can intellectually know this
isn't good for me i don't want this i'm
moving on
but your body can still be very much
addicted
to that person who looked at you at the
wedding ceremony and said i'm all in on
you too
there's something really intoxicating
about that right
yeah
and so at some point you're gonna have
to i wish i had different language here
you have to detox from that person how
often do y'all communicate
once every month and it's
a text message or two about
some stuff we're still working on
settling dividing
um
but really it's
not that often in fact we we don't even
live in the same part of the country she
lives completely across the country okay
um so physically seeing her obviously is
not even a thought
um
it kind of is a thought isn't it
it
it hasn't been in a while and i can and
i feel like i'm being honest when i say
that because
it
there was a lot you know the last time i
saw her would have been in
january
and it was
it was very hard yeah um but actually it
felt like it was a good way to close the
door cool okay um
so it was it was the closure that i
needed to move on obviously that doesn't
make the situation any easier right
you're with somebody for a decade but
that was she hey brother she was the air
you breathe
she was the thought she was
she was in the terms and the terms that
i put it in was she wasn't the son to my
universe but she was one of my planets
ah okay
if that makes sense there there was
there was a lot of important things in
my life and you know she was
one of the top important things in my
life and maybe at times she did become
the son and that's where i have to look
at myself and say i i definitely could
have done that better so give me one or
two things that um you'll do differently
next time
put my needs first
what does that mean
um
speak up if there's
speak up if i'm not okay instead of
consistently trying to give parts of
myself
to a point to where i'm not in an okay
place and then i can't be
everything that i am in a relationship
or friendship for that matter because
i'm too worried about how's the other
person feeling is the other person happy
um
am i giving my all so that way that
you know they they will love me which i
i tell that that's completely not true i
want to challenge you okay
the things you just laid out are all
about performance
someone who loves you is going to need
you to do some things when it comes to
meeting their needs right
but love is
starts with you looking in the mirror
and saying i'm worth being loved man
and you don't believe that
we're going to need a whole other call
for that
i know i know but listen anytime
somebody answers the way you just did
my heart breaks for you
because somebody should have told you a
long long time ago
that you've got value
that the because the the question
underneath the question i just asked you
is what does that mean and you said well
then i'm going to let my needs be heard
when i'm not okay
and i would say well you've got to
define what not okay means which means
you've got to define what okay means
which means you've got to define
what do i want with this one crazy
little life i got
and what am i worth what is my time
worth
and here's what i'll tell you not just a
fast four dollar because i know that's
probably a whole other call you're worth
being loved recklessly
you're worth somebody rolling over in
the middle of the night and waking you
up just to kiss you on the on the mouth
because why not
and you deserve to fall in bed asleep
without meds and you deserve to get up
in the morning
and have a cup of coffee because you
want to not because you have to
and you are worth a job that doesn't
take your soul from you but it also is
an addiction either because you're
probably a workaholic too if i we want
to go to another phone call is that fair
yeah yeah i actually i
i have a pretty decent work-life balance
i will say that but i am a busy person i
have to stay busy there you go
all it says this um
when you can look in the mirror and say
i love that guy or let me say this way
you probably talk to yourself in a way
that you would never let somebody talk
to a stranger in your presence
i
so i've been doing john i've been doing
therapy for about two years now okay are
you working on self-talk
oh yeah okay i
i consistently
i want to go back to the person that i
was when i was 10 and i just want to
hold him and i just want to hug him have
you done that because
uh i have to do it a lot okay
and i just
what happened to 10 year old alex
uh
10 year old alex
was
very very publicly embarrassed because
of his weight okay by two strangers
and it started a whole
whole
um 15 20 years worth of
very very bad body dysmorphia eating
disorders
um over training under eating over
eating
um
because i looked in the mirror every day
and said i hate the person that i was
there you go
man
and i'm not and i'm very proud to say
that i i love myself and that's and
that's you know one of the reasons why
why i made this call is because
i do want to own
right everything that i had i want to
own that i went through that i want but
i don't want it to define me right
right
so listen let it go
set it down
you can't control your way through what
happens next
and yeah that's hard
it's real because here's why your
solution to
those mean people who embarrassed you
publicly
was this will never happen again
right
and this will never happen again comes
from some really firm resolve and that
resolve is really good
and our culture celebrates that resolve
it's good for you
to make some major behavioral changes
and to make some health changes all it's
good and then it becomes pathological
because the same behaviors that kept us
alive when we were kids kill us when
we're adults right
and so uh and it melts our relationships
so
the next path through is letting it go
have you written that 10 year old alex a
letter
yeah okay yeah i have was that good a
good experience
good
good good is the wrong word it led into
a lot more than just the letter it led
into a
a book per se good good that is saved on
a word file it's about 150 pages good
for you good for you
so now so here's the thing i read that a
lot now let's let's um so you you went
you've been through seasons of some
pretty intense exercise
okay
so let's um
let's take the next few steps and this
is for everybody listen
let's take the next few steps as though
it's an exercise plan okay
and what we're going to what i mean by
that is
you can't go just run a marathon
tomorrow
and so you're gonna have to you have to
start practicing
and you've seen the couch to 5k and the
couch to marathon on the couch to 10k
we're gonna do couch to well okay you've
got two years of therapy you know you've
been able to identify the epicenter
and i would even tell you that in many
ways you've talked about it enough
so here's a couple of things i'm gonna
give you as the path out okay
number one um
you probably have a daily gratitude
practice of some sort but i want you to
get in the habit of that okay
okay
the second thing is is i want you to
implement a weekly service into your
life and not even mowing somebody money
but find a place where you can volunteer
an hour here's what we're doing we're
getting outside of our head and we're
taking that camera that has been
scanning the inside of you for a long
time and we're going to point it outward
we're going to stop looking at the rear
view mirror we'll start looking at the
at the at the windshield okay
okay this is a practice and so just
getting out and seeing other people and
helping people meet needs
um is an invaluable practice okay
it's um there's some data that suggests
it's a path out of depression it's a
path out of some of these behaviors
are you a part of any sort of men's
group
um
i actually just moved to dallas about
three months ago so i'm looking for one
in person but i am a part of a couple
like virtual based okay i want you to
get off the computer and get with people
in real life
okay okay
um
get with some human beings in your
immediate area and there's gonna be some
sort of
um
lovaholics anonymous or essay group or
whatever like there's gonna be some some
groups there that you can circle up with
and just have another group of men in
your life okay
um i show up once a quarter to a group
here in nashville right so
to check in and and to help out but also
man i need to show up too
um
uh
the the the title of the book escapes me
here but it's by pia melody
p-i-a-m-e-l-o-d-y
and i think the title might be love
addiction i want you to pick that book
up um
she's the
guru um just a really powerful powerful
read
but here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna start practicing
not performing
we're gonna practice
i need to whenever you hear the words i
need to or i should i want you to stop
and be curious about that what do i need
to do right now
what i have to do right now versus
i'm good i'm good
right it's hard man it's hard
so what i just
one one last quick question what would
you what would your advice
be to me
if i'm meeting somebody whether that be
a work or a social based event and
they're asking me about myself and it's
uh you know oh hi my name is so and so
and i am
they ask are you married you're getting
kids no divorce or thinking you know
whatever the answer is and then that's
that automatic label
that's
all yours that is that is your baggage
if you meet somebody
and you feel the need to explain your
marital status
that's you
bringing that to that conversation
if they ask you are you married and you
go no not married divorced
and they choose
to create a story about you what that
word means about you you don't want to
spend time with that person
right exactly okay
so don't take that extra baggage with
you and this is gonna be something you
practice
okay
you have made the word divorce a scarlet
letter
wait and and
so when when i went through my divorce
um
even i was a part of some in person i
did some virtual as well but a lot of
support groups
and i ended up leaving them in about two
weeks
because
these people were just
they were so angry i mean they were
rightfully so yeah i mean i i was i was
disappointed i was angry but like
i still don't regret it
um
so so but yeah you left those groups
thinking that you something's wrong with
you or you left those groups with some
sort of introspection that i'm not angry
like this i don't want to be around this
but am i not doing this right am i right
yeah exactly i felt like well what is
wrong with me because they keep telling
me that you should be so mad you should
be so no no listen listen
that is
love addiction
you are outsourcing your feelings to
other people
in the hopes that they will do it better
than you can do it
and that's a person who innately does
not trust themselves
and underneath that is a person who
innately does not love themselves
see what i'm saying
who cares what a group of strangers on
the internets think about you
who cares they don't get a vote
they don't get a vote right
it's cool for them to help out and say
hey here's a common experience we're
having
but if your body says dude there's a
bunch of angry people and yeah i'm
heartbroken it was hard but it was right
right um well and that's the thing is is
like i'm still like i'm still here i'm
still proud of myself yes and everything
that i've done and like that's where i'm
like i don't need this then don't yeah
then walk away you're there you just
gotta take that last step
hold your head up high
you're alex from freaking dallas texas
hold your head up high
low star state
hey hold your head up high okay
you went through something hard you had
to make some hard decisions you had to
look in the mirror you've done two years
of hard therapy
you have some early traumas that you've
been wrestling with you've done a ton of
heavy heavy lifting
and it's kind of like this
you know you uh
um you probably experienced this right
when you were really focused on weight
loss and i'm gonna be thin you'd run
into people that hadn't seen you in a
while
and they were like whoa you look great
and you didn't see it like that because
you just seen it little bits and pieces
every day over the course of one year
two years ten years however long
that's you right now
so in a weightlifting metaphor you
have been lifting in a
dim lit rocky iv style gym for the last
couple of years
heavy lifting hard
and then you just came out in the light
and you don't realize how big you've
gotten how muscular you've gotten how
strong you've gotten how good you look
and you're gonna go back to the same
people who have the same labels as you
and they haven't put the work in you've
put in or they're at the very beginning
of their journey they're just heading
into that gym
that's great that's good this is not
where you are right now and so those are
people we're going to love we're going
to walk alongside them if they invite us
as mentors and friends
but we're not going to
we're not going to work out with them
they can't lift our weight they can't
even spot us
we're going to surround ourselves with
real people in the world that are going
to do life with us and dude you have to
decide to put that label down it is it
just is
so i'm going to hold my head up high
when i meet people yeah i'm divorced if
you want to dig into it more
my wife cheated on me and i'm a person
of character and standards and i believe
that um
my uh covenant stands for something
and my wife violated covenant i love her
lover good friend good human uh but
violated our covenant and so i'm not
gonna remain there
they want to get into it right
but they're not going to that's you
bringing your baggage to that label set
it down man
i'm really really proud of the work
you've done alex we've come a long long
way now it's time to enact it now it's
time to start taking those little baby
steps towards a new marathon a whole new
way of being alive
and i start to look in the mirror and
saying i'm alex and
i've got value
i'm worth being loved starting with you
my brother i'm proud of you we'll be
right back
hey dr john dolone here and it's that
time again school is back summer is
winding down and it's time to get back
to the routines we threw out the window
back in may pick up drop off get up
early no more ice cream for dinner on
most days your schedules are probably
about to go bonkers but i've got a
reminder for you for the love of all
that is good make sure you prioritize
sleep for your kids for your marriage
for your job
for you getting seven to nine hours of
deep rejuvenating sleep is one of the
best things you can do for your health
not doom scrolling on instagram or
zoning out with netflix all night we all
need sleep and for me good sleep starts
with a great mattress and that's why i
love dream cloud mattresses and right
now dream cloud is making it easy with a
great deal just for our listeners
599 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's a total
of 849 dollars in accessories and
savings i'm talking pillows a mattress
protector and luxury sheets to go along
with a great mattress so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloney to get your new
mattress today
all right we are back let's go to lauren
in reading california what's up lauren
hey how are you doing we are rocking on
to the breaking dawn what are you doing
i'm just hoping you'd say that i wanted
to joke about it but you beat me to it
okay hey hold on i gotta i gotta say my
sister is actually the one who invented
that and um i guess she got was on the
internets or something in some like she
and she texted me the other day out of
the blue and it's like hey you need to
cite me when you say that so this is me
signing her so there we go lauren all
right so what's up
okay so i'm a little nervous but i try
to i'm i'm real nervous really nervous
yeah i know you always tell people that
that's why i'm i'm calming down here so
um
i
i'm a teacher i'm a mom i'm actually an
adjunct professor and so
um children are kind of like
my expertise and i'm sitting here as a
parent
and my son is five and i don't know how
to navigate this loss related to fire
that we've been having
um
so his his child care burned down two
weeks ago oh yeah yeah
i also have a two-year-old yeah and so
i'm really curious um what your take on
like navigating that discussion would be
with both of them in an age-appropriate
way that's a great question i was in um
in fact kelly and i were in san jose
yesterday two days ago
um
and it was both so beautiful
and the fire threats everywhere it was
just it was astounding it was wild right
um i'm so sorry you're going through
that man what a mess that is
um here's the best i've found working
with um this sort of loss and ultimately
trauma with with a five-year-old okay
very different than with a two-year-old
um
a couple of rules of thumb that i follow
and this is stuff that i do in my own
home by the way okay so it's not just
like
bullet points out of a textbook
one is it's really important for your
kids to see you be sad too
and we often think that we have to be
strong for them and an oak for them and
that is true we do have to get up and go
to work we do have to provide food we do
have to do those adult things
but when we don't show our kids that
we're sad too that we're scared too that
we're heartbroken too it makes them feel
nuts
like mommy's really strong right now and
she doesn't seem to be upset about this
i must be crazy or i must be weak or i
must be dysfunctional i need to figure
out how i can not be sad about hard
things so i can be like her or like
daddy right and so it's saying no mom's
really really sad
one thing i would do with the
five-year-old is i would
get some paper out and some matte
pencils some and i'd go get some nice
ones um because we're doing this
not therapeutically but we're doing this
for a reason i get some nice markers or
some nice pencils and we would draw a
picture
let's draw a picture of a scary fire
like let's draw it and talk about it and
not talking about it doesn't make it go
away
i'm talking about it shines light on it
and here is an important second part of
that
um
i would also
have your five-year-old is five-year-old
little girl little boy
he's a boy and the the caveat here i
guess where i struggle a little bit is
that he's um language delayed as well
okay
and so his understanding of really
complex topics is it's a little
it's a little harder for him to
understand right that's where art is so
important
art in relationship okay and you see how
drawing a picture together is important
and if mommy draws it too
then we're doing this together and we
can talk about it he may not be able to
verbalize it but he'll be able to feel
you
and here's the important part when you
draw this you'll have emotions also
most of the time when somebody calls me
and says how do i tell my five-year-old
something
they're also wondering how they tell
themselves something
yeah that's what i've been discussing
with um like i reached out to some
people here in my area just because i i
waited a long time to tell him because
the thought of it you know left me in
tears and i
i there's like multiple layers there i
mean this is the place where
there's a lot to grease this is the
place where he learned how to talk and
this is like a legendary child care it's
an example for all of the providers out
there
and then the people that own it are just
fabulous loving wonderful people like
it's my kid's second home yeah or it was
i'm seeing even that i have to
acknowledge that it's yeah so
you know what you're saying makes a lot
of sense and that was the thing i think
i was most afraid of was falling apart
in front of my kids
i i i have i think that's healthy for
them falling apart is different like you
can't fall apart and then
go be stay in bed for two weeks and say
y'all just fitting for yourselves right
but letting them see you cry is
important but here's there's a really
important second half to this
so we're gonna acknowledge the fears and
we're gonna talk about them
i would really love it if you and this
five-year-old could do something like
bake cookies
together and
you could also show him fire on the
stove
and this fire is gonna help make these
cookies that we're gonna take to mr and
mrs smith who lost their business
and so here's what we're getting there
we are teaching at a very young age that
there's a lot of scary awful things in
the world
it just is
and the way through fear and the way
through anxiety they have
counter reinforcement measures so the
more we run from it the tighter they
spin and the faster they go the louder
those alarms get the further away we try
to get from them
and so i'm gonna lean into that fear
so fire took something away
fire also gives us something really cool
and then
underneath all of that is one of the
paths out is service
where do i take that energy that's just
balled up in me i can netflix it away i
can numb it away i can have all sorts of
addictive ways to wallpaper over it or i
can go serve
and so you you can knock out a few
things in one and one fell swoop there
we can have some time talking about fire
and
uh even if you drew a picture that he's
going to get put in a cart right now i'm
not suggesting he draw a building with a
fire flames on it something like that
don't
don't don't crystallize that image of
this building but y'all can draw fire
and talk about that it's scary
and then you can
go show him
look at this look how cool this fire is
when it's under control and it it gives
us something so good and so we're gonna
lean into it right um
here's another thing
there's a lot of fires in the news and
things like that which is important to
keep up with we all have to be having
these conversations my home state of
texas has just
been on fire all summer
um
there comes a point though that
a five-year-old and even you bathing in
the data on a daily basis is
counterproductive it's not good for you
yeah with the first fire that we had the
car fire up here and it was like you
know within a mile of my house and so we
had to evacuate and he was only a year
old and then daddy was a first responder
and had to leave so we were separated
from daddy
and
i mean then the second one was right by
a school so i'm a teacher there i had to
evacuate my class yeah so so i had to go
home so there's been a lot he's
definitely showing some anxiety around
fires
here's here's the main the main avenue
of that
oh
i'm i'm taking
like close your eyes real quick
and picture me and you
just sitting down
like at a table okay
with me with a smile on my face okay
got it
i'm saying this and i absolutely 100
know i'm wading into waters that as a
mom is gonna is not smart okay but i
want to be honest with you okay
most of the fire related fear that a
five-year-old's gonna have
um is gonna be absorbed from their
caregivers
for sure yeah and so
i that doesn't mean you have to try to
hide your anxiety and your stress and
your fear and your frustration with
fires
that means that you've got to do make
sure you've got people you're talking to
obviously your five-year-old can't be
your
therapist
you've got to have people that you talk
to and you communicate with and you
grieve with and you get the stuff out um
but your kids are gonna pick up that
tension from you
okay
um and so letting them know like no i've
got a process for it too yeah i was
really scared and sad mom's very very
sad that the school went away
very sad um let's draw a picture of fire
fire can be scary right
um fire can also be really good you
wanna do something neat with fire yeah
and now we're gonna do something cool
and we're gonna make cookies for people
um and that's just one little thing
you're you're create you're a teacher
you're way more creative than i am would
be on something like that um
the two-year-old is not going to have a
clue even what day it is like you know
what i mean but they are but your
two-year-old is going to absorb you
yeah two-year-old's going to absorb
no my two-year-old um we actually i only
told my five-year-old i wasn't quite
ready but i i told him
after the fact because i was taking my
two-year-old to visit a new facility
because i have to go back to work soon
and
we got really lucky and found a place
near our home and so um
we went over there but i told her this
was going to be her new school and she
stopped us but real big will fit
that fit is
let's get some bananas let her have that
fit
i did yeah i did yeah she's just sad she
said and maybe she writes a letter to
the building let's write like how much
we're going to miss you or whatever but
yeah
that she's going to be overwhelmed
because that place was safe and for you
that's where she learned to talk but for
her that's where her body felt safe that
she could do some of these things that
the other kids could do you know what
i'm saying like this is a anchor point
this is a like uh environment that was
safe that's gonna be hard
um
ugh i'm sorry y'all going through this
thank you but i'll tell you this i'm
really glad that she's got a
conscientious mom and dad like y'all
or he does to to
walk through him with this
yeah and i'm hoping this call will give
other i mean because there's multiple
parents people had their kids there that
day when it happened and they they
barely got out in time
the big thing with
with
walking kids through scary situations is
not ignoring it
um and our tendency is to let's don't
talk about it i don't want to bring it
up i don't want to cause any more
problems and that buries it yeah
and art and relationship have a just an
unbelievable way of healing and bringing
people together and it's a way i can sit
by you but i don't have to make eye
contact with you and sometimes i'll i'll
draw something that brings a tear to my
eye that my kid can see or we'll watch a
movie together
um and then we're gonna go do something
constructive with that but um yes thank
you your call is gonna help folks who
are sitting there whether it's a kid
who's experiencing divorce for the first
time or
daddy passed away or school burned down
or whatever is going on in our lives
engaging our kids
engaging our kids whether it's picking
up some toys and playing taking them to
a counselor or sitting and coloring
pictures and then teaching them how to
serve is such a gift to them and
it's a gift to you
make sure you're grieving this too we'll
be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's johndaloney.com
today
all right as we wrap up today's show i
want to thank lauren for that last call
uh i'm really grateful for that people
working through hard stuff with their
kids um that's important um
in honor of i have a friend named
preston who works here with me um
brilliant guy
um
one of the craziest third eye blind fans
you'll ever meet um i'm pretty sure he
has a third blind tattoo
um like up and down his arm it's uh
he wears suits a lot he wears shirts and
ties and so you don't see it all the
time but one of the biggest fans and so
this is just my way of honoring preston
um with his favorite third eyeblind song
by the way
can't stand them invited him to the show
last night got some tickets and his
quote was i'd rather eat a urinal cake
so great so in honor of preston his
favorite song
jumper and it goes like this
i wish you would step back from the
ledge my friend you could cut ties with
all the lies that you've been living in
and if you don't want to see me again i
understand
the angry boy a bit too insane icing
over a secret pain you know you don't
belong and you're the first to fight and
you're way too loud
you got the the flash of light on a
burial shroud i know something's wrong
and everyone i know has got a reason to
say put the past away
but i wish you would step back from the
ledge my friend i wish you would step
back preston
i'm glad we're best friends see you soon